on a plaisir de recevoir alain saulnier
pour en parler bonsoir un bâtonnier
professeur invité au département de
communication de l'université de
montréal est aussi ancien directeur de
l'information radio canada de 2006 à
2012 alors d'abord il demandait que
l'annoncé d'aujourd'hui 5 millions de
dollars qui comme le précise et me
suffit tribune se double d'un plan de
restructuration
trop peu trop tard suffisant mais je
pense qu'il était urgent d'agir
rapidement
le sisqa le ministre a fait je pense
aussi qu'il était important que j'ai un
regard sur la gestion sur la suite des
choses parce que on donne pas de
l'argent en accumulant les millions $
coup après coup
en même temps ce qui est certain c'est
que ce n'est qu'à court terme
et puis elle vient de garantie pour la
suite des choses ça reste toujours tout
aussi préoccupant mais heureusement on a
réussi à mon point de vue à gagner un
peu de temps pour tenter de voir si et
pas moyen de refaire ce modèle pour
qu'on puisse que publiés au cours des
prochains jours
on a fait un journal c'est une tragédie
en fait pour les gens de la région c'est
une tragédie pour nous pour que
l'analyste
mais parce que la démocratie régionale
la démocratie des citoyens des citoyens
des régions ça s'exprime à travers des
journaux régionaux s'intéresse
activement auprès des médias régionaux
bon bien sûr radio canada fait un bon
travail mais ce n'est pas suffisant il
faut car il est aussi des médias de leak
et ricky ont comme on les appelait
autrefois pour remplir cette mission
aura donc c'est essentiel à la
démocratie qu d'avoir des médias
régionaux
et si on en a pas on affaiblit justement
la participation des citoyens à la vie
démocratique
on l'a vu tantôt il ya eu d'autres près
par le passé le million un peu plus d'un
million 5 millions aujourd'hui
juste pour ce groupe là ce groupe
médiatique logique à quel point c'est le
rôle de l'état d'être le sauveur dans
tout ça est ce que d'autres acteurs dans
la société aussi qu'ils pouvaient venir
en aide à ces médias les moyens sûrement
d'autres acteurs qui pourraient le faire
il faut comprendre
par contre que le modèle d'affaires qui
s'appuyait sur la publie la revue
il a éclaté totalement ça n'existe plus
quand à eux seuls de google et facebook
sont capables de 80% des revenus
publicitaires et cela avec la complicité
des gouvernements faut-il le souligner
puisque et l'immédiat on joue et
d'angelin aussi aussi qui ont évité les
gens les partager sur facebook qu'il a
fait puis ça veut dire que ça leur donne
des contenus à leur façon des
entreprises de service facebook et les
réseaux sociaux
alors les limites et les rendements
aussi j'allais dire on joue un rôle de
complice une certaine manière parce que
ils plaçaient leurs annonces
publicitaires dans les sur facebook
plutôt que dans les meilleurs régionaux
on entendait le maire de gatineau qui
parlait de battre du quotidien de sur la
qualité et de ce qui va en advenir mais
il disait si le modèle d'affaires qu'il
faut revoir vous le dis encore une
famille comment fait pour s'en prendre à
ces géants la du numérique sont google
et les autres gaffes à qui on qui
vraiment sûr venus brouiller les cartes
quel est le modèle idéal pour que ça
marche les médias une information
diversifiée indépendante en région au
sein de plusieurs questions à ce que
vous dites
la première des choses c'est qu'il faut
apprendre à cohabiter avec les géants du
web sont n'a plus le choix ils sont là
pour s'établir ils sont alors établi
contrôler complètement l'univers
numérique
cu en fait les véritables propriétaires
de l'univers numérique
nous on est là qu on essaie d'avoir une
classe à l'intérieur de ça devient
ridicule comment les taxes alors il faut
que les gouvernements que les états
puissent établir des règles du jeu
d'équité fiscale des règles du jeu aussi
pour que les règlements de la
réglementation nationale soit appliquée
je pense que ça prend aussi des impôts
mais aussi des taxes sur le chiffre
d'affaires mais aussi sur les profits
parce que jusqu'à maintenant la plupart
de ces géants du web se faufile à peu
près ce que tout ce qui s'appelle
territoire et non pas très cher
l'inconnu en le prenant une ou médias
mais
en profitait ce qui devrait payer pour
ce contenu oui d'abord une question de
droit de retard dans un premier temps
et puis il ya certainement des enfants
qui doivent être établies entre les
géants du web et les médias qui sont en
grande partie la nourriture les contenus
qui sont proposés par facebook et par
les différents réseaux sociaux
alors oui il faut qu'on trouve une
nouvelle solution un nouveau modèle
d'affaires il n'est pas trouvé celui
qu'il l'a il pourrait faire une fois
stationné hier dans le monde non plus en
fait ailleurs dans le monde on se pose
les mêmes questions se posent les mêmes
questions mais regardez il ya en france
où on a osé s'attaquer au chiffre
d'affaires avec une taxe de 3% sur le
chiffre d'affaires des géants du web
mais cette opération là n'est pas suivi
par tous les autres pays européens
alors c'est pour ça que non seulement
les états doivent se concerter entre eux
mais établir des règles du jeu qui soit
à peu près similaire pour qu'ensemble
ils fassent un front commun contre les
géants du web
et quand l'état aide comme ça délie les
cordons de la bourse
ce qui est un détail et une indépendance
à protéger est ce que là dessus sur ce
front là on peut être tranquille quand
même cédé que dans les mesures qui ont
été annoncées par le gouvernement
libéral fédéral par monsieur trudeau il
y avait un élément d'un qui permettait
de garantir une forme d'indépendance à
l'égard de l'état et donc on se retrouve
pas en situation de dépendance
maintenant dans les prochaines mesures à
trouver ici au québec ou ailleurs à
ottawa ils vont former c'est seulement
quand nécessairement qu on essaie de
trouver une façon qu'il ya toujours ce
mur étanche entre eux le média et l'état
par exemple parce qu'on pourrait penser
éventuellement a donné un déduction
d'impôt pour quelqu'un qui s'abonnent
journal pourquoi est ce qu'on pense pas
à ce genre de mesures lancées çà
encouragerait les gens pourquoi est ce
qu'on pense pas non plus avoir des
formules dead pour les annonceurs
publicitaires régionaux pour qu'ils
aillent plutôt du côté des meilleurs
régionaux que du côté des réseaux
sociaux
il faudra être créatif il faudra être
très très créatif on n'a pas le choix
tout à fait ce soliste toujours un
plaisir un autre chaîne nova